der titel des heutigen videos der war
echt schwierig zu finden weil er dem
super spannenden thema gerecht werden
musste und euch auch dafür
interessieren sollte man es wirklich
sehr wichtig es geht um drogensucht und
meinen damit verbundenen superkräfte
und wie man mit einer impfung von der
drogensucht loskommen kann also alles
super spannend sind klick zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen also um es
vorweg zu nehmen ich habe tatsächlich
eine etwas seltsame eigenschaft man
könnte sie als superkräfte bezeichnen
also was bei mir wirklich seltsam ist
bei mir wirken drogen einfach nicht ich
hab ich schon einiges genommen aber
nichts wirkt außer alkohol von dem
werde ich tatsächlich betrunken aber
alles andere hat bei mir einfach keine
wirkung egal was ich nehme es passiert
einfach nichts letztlich in amsterdam
musste ich einen ganzen joint rauchen
weil die leute es einfach nicht glauben
wollten und auch da es passierte nichts
rein gar nichts und das ist natürlich
super ob es superkräfte sind naja aber
es hat schon vorteile ich kann nie
drogensüchtig werden das ist natürlich
wirklich klasse aber das ist jetzt auch
für jeden möglich und es ist
vielleicht die erklärung für meine
unempfindlichkeit für drogen
forscherinnen und forscher um kinder und
port bremer vom scripps research
institute in den usa haben jetzt einen
impfstoff gegen heroin entwickelt und
der funktioniert tatsächlich wie eine
impfung
sie hat das team den wirkstoff an
rhesusaffen getestet sie verwendeten
abgeschwächte heroin moleküle die sie
an einen tetanus bestandteil als träger
banken
dieser wirkstoff sollte das immunsystem
trainieren das heroin als fremdkörper
zu erkennen und entsprechende
antikörper zu bilden und tatsächlich
bildeten die affen spezielle antikörper
die sich an das heroin an lagerten und
so verhinderten dass das heroin die
blut-hirn-schranke überwinden konnte
der rausch blieb aus bei tests
funktioniert er das perfekt und die
wirkung des heroins wurde um das
fünfzehnfache abgeschwächt und der
impfstoff wirkte sogar mindestens acht
monate lang jetzt wollen die forscher
und forscherinnen erste klinische tests
mit menschen machen die genehmigung
dafür müsste es schnell geben denn
alle bestandteile des impfstoffs sind
bereits bei anderen anwendungen
zugelassen das wäre ein sehr
vielversprechender weg um heroin
abhängige von der droge los
zu lassen aber das beste ist natürlich
erst gar nicht drogenabhängig zu werden
deshalb respekt vor drogen und egal ob
alkohol haschisch mdma täter und so
weiter und so fort seit extrem
vorsichtig drogen sind nichts tolles
weil sie ja wohlbefinden nur simulieren
sich richtig wohlfühlen das ist das
allerbeste
denn von drogen wieder loszukommen ist
wirklich sehr schwierig diese impfung
wird es in zukunft ausschließlich für
heroin geben ob andere wirkstoffe noch
für andere drogen gefunden werden das
steht noch in den sternen wir werden
euch natürlich hier informieren wenn es
etwas neues gibt
wer nichts verpassen wollt dann drückt
mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke hier also hier
geht es weiter mit einem komplett
betrunken christoph und meinem
alkoholtest mit vielen infos zu der
droge wer mich also mal volltrunken
sehen wollt dann nur zu klicks auf das
video und habt euren spaß ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran